[Music]
2018 was a difficult year to sum up at
times it felt chaotic at times it felt
surreal at times it felt strangely calm
and in the world of video games the same
rang true it was a year of sleeper hits
and astounding disappointments as old
heroes returned juggernauts began their
streak and veteran studios took major
missteps the news surrounding games was
just as varied with developer
acquisitions proceeding massive studio
closures conversations arose about
working conditions and harmful company
cultures and each new day kept us on our
toes that's why I waited for 2018 to
officially be over before making this
video it was one of those years that you
can only see clearly in the rearview
mirror right off the bat Monster Hunter
world transformed Capcom's cult
role-playing series into a commercial
hit the newest entry brought the
franchise to Sony and Microsoft consoles
as well as PC selling 11 million copies
as of last fall it's now Capcom's best
selling game ever stealing the crown
from the long reigning Resident Evil 5
and who among us doesn't remember
playing God of War slowly realizing that
Santa Monica studio had taken one of
videogames most generic characters and
given him profound depth God of War
would go on to win numerous Game of the
Year accolades at IGN polygons and the
game awards show marking a turning point
for a franchise that a few years ago was
all but dead
speaking of redeemed characters 2018
also saw the return of Marvel's web
slinging superhero as insomniac
spider-man accrued nominations and
awards it drew comparisons to 2004 as
revered spider-man 2 with thrilling
movement mechanics frenetic combat and a
surprisingly gripping story it marked a
renaissance for the Marvel character but
also the developer itself targeting back
to its halcyon days with ratchet & clank
resistance and spyro and as one last
note on spider-man it's also the fastest
selling PlayStation exclusive of all
time staying in the realm of Sales
veteran developer Rockstar Games
released its long-awaited Red Dead
Redemption - and
as is customary with the studios titles
sauce sales of ludicrous proportions
it sold 17 million copies to customers
and retailers in its first 12 days and
outsold the lifetime sales of the first
Red Dead Redemption an 8 year old game
in its first 8 days but Red Dead 2 was
risky in terms of design rockstars
newest release forces you to take your
time plan your travels and move at a
slow deliberate pace as westerns go it's
more of a Lonesome Dove than a 3:10 to
Yuma and in GameSpot's humble correct
opinion this approach paid off the
aforementioned games all succeeded in
one way or another be it critical
adoration or commercial records but 2018
was not without its triple-a missteps in
March I conic developer rare released
its multiplayer games sea of thieves and
while its premise had promised it soon
became clear that most of its appeal
rested on the surface see if thieves has
its advocates and rare has work to
expand it after its release but by and
large its bare-bones design made it an
afterthought as the months passed a
similar scenario occurred later in the
year as bethesda game studios made its
own pivot into the multiplayer sphere
fallout 76 released with an array of
boring quests a lifeless world and a
slew of bugs - boo many players lost
their save files completely within two
weeks of its release fallout 76 had
drawn the ire of redditors Steam users
and longtime Bethesda fans alike for all
the ups and downs of the triple-a
release cycle 2018 was defined just as
much if not more by its phenomenal indie
lineup in january developers matt
Thorsten and noel bairey along with a
small team released celeste
the demanding 2d platformer that doubles
as a parable about living with mental
health like the best games of its genre
it expertly introduces new mechanics
throughout the play through morphing a
simple premise into a complex video game
shortly thereafter subset games released
into the breach it plays like a
dangerous game of chess strewn with
explosives hulking mechs and vicious
kaiju across several locales it's a
stunning display of effective
simplicity that remains exciting after
hundreds of hours after about a year in
early access developer motion twin
released its roguelike darling dead
cells to critical acclaim its seamless
blend of 2d combat Metroidvania
exploration and RPG weapon progression
made it one of the year's best releases
it's one of those games that's rewarding
every step of the way several months
after return of the oh burden became the
sleeper hit among the rush of holiday
releases created by papers please
developer Lucas Pope oh burden places
players in the shoes of an insurance
agent investigating the disappearance of
the titular ship's crew with
supernatural elements a fragmented
narrative and clever time travel
abilities it's being lauded as one of
the best detective games to date as for
one of the year's best games that didn't
actually release in 2018 hallow night
made its way to Nintendo switch drawing
far more attention than its 2017 PC
release it combines an ominous
foreboding world with challenging combat
and a refusal to hold players hands it
was one of several titles that found new
life on Nintendo's portable console it's
funny because Nintendo was actually
criticized for its plethora of
third-party releases many accused the
company of padding an otherwise quiet
year outside of Pokemon let's go super
mario party mario tennis aces and super
smash bros ultimate
but to me Nintendo's third-party lineup
was one of 2018 s bright spots it not
only let me play some of my favorite
games on the go but it also rekindled my
love for games I had already poured
dozens of hours into Microsoft's
exclusive portfolio was once again
sparse with the excellent Forza horizon
4 and the underrated state of decay -
picking up much of the slack left by sea
of thieves but upon taking a closer look
it's clear that Microsoft actually had a
great year it released its new adaptive
controller allowing passionate fans with
disabilities to further enjoy the games
they loved it made good on its promise
of more backwards compatibility adding
numerous classics to the Xbox one's
library it also brought in millions of
players into its Netflix like
subscription service game pass and
finally Microsoft made several massive
studio acquisitions adding veterans such
as obsidian ninja theory and undead labs
to its first party team Sony on the
other hand relied almost entirely on its
exclusives the success of spider-man and
God of War aside ps4 also served as a
home for ninokuni to Detroit become
human
Yakuza 6 and Yakuza kiwami to glue point
games also gave shadow the colossus a
fantastic remaster bringing the classic
back to gorgeous life and of course this
list would not be complete without
Tetris effect developers resin Aaron
Monstars revived the legendary title to
universal acclaim
it's a dazzling display of sight sound
and euphoric sensory overload and it's
all the more effective and V are in fact
2018 was strewn with excellent VR titles
Tetris effect drew the most attention
but we also had Maus firewall zero our
beat saber and the astonishing Astro bot
rescue mission as opposed to previous
year's VR developers seemed less
concerned with releasing proofs of
concept and more focused on just
releasing incredible games I don't think
it's bold to say that 2018 was the best
year for VR to date
[Music]
for all of the news that emerged 2018
was also a sobering reminder that there
are thousands of people behind the games
we play in August
Kotaku published an article about the
sexist culture at League of Legends
developer Riot Games reporter Cecilia
Don Stassi Oh spoke to 28 current and
former employees whose accounts painted
the picture of an environment hostile
toward women
the phrase Bro culture cropped up on
several different occasions women often
felt degraded and objectified and
numerous cases of alleged sexual
misconduct came out in these interviews
following the report riot claimed it
would double its efforts to investigate
claims of harassment in the workplace
but in December when the company
suspended CEO of Scott Gelb for two
months of unpaid leave many Rai
employees felt the punishment was too
soft Gelb was said to regularly harassed
employees perpetuating a fraternity
mindset based around bathroom humor and
it's alleged efforts to right the ship
riot still clearly has problems to
address and in the case of rockstar
games the conversation about working
conditions took on a very different form
in October New York magazine published a
feature about the making of Red Dead
Redemption to the publication spoke at
length with Dan Hauser
rockstars co-founder and lead writer
about the effort put into the massive
Western in a now infamous quote Houser
said the team spent multiple hundred
hour weeks to bring Red Dead 2 to
fruition Houser later clarified he was
only referring to the core writers in
this quote and after speaking with
dozens of former and current Rockstar
members Kotaku's Jason Schreyer
published a story about this culture of
crunch the reports as Schreyer wrote
were complicated and sometimes
contradictory many Rockstar employees
didn't work overtime others did but
found it to be rewarding others still
said the job cost them their closest
relationships and that the studio
fostered a mentality in which weekends
and nights were expected of them
rockstar studio culture became the focus
of the ongoing discussion about the
ethics of crunch and of course the
discussion did not end with red Dead's
gargantuan release in the wake of the
game success questions arose regarding
how much of the games affecting
narrative
an obsessive amount of detail were a
result of overtime is crunch necessary
to make games of this nature will things
change in the future how many other
Triple A Studios might have practices
like this that we have no idea about
2018 was a reminder that these questions
and the stories of numerous employees
with diverse backgrounds are just as
important as the games themselves we
witnessed the end of telltale games in
September reports of poor management and
that same pervasive crunch emerged 250
employees showed up for work one day and
only hours later discovered they have
lost their jobs
crunch culture may not have been the
only cause but it was a cause
nonetheless it's easy to remember 2018
as a grim year for every game that
elevated the medium just as much bad
news seemed to bring it back down but in
moving forward it's important to
recognize the bright spots as well not
just the examples of what not to do but
also the ones that show us how things
can be done French developer motion twin
creator of indie darling dead cells
stresses work-life balance as its main
pillar it has no seniority it has no
executives each member makes the same
salary as the next and of course the
studio also made one of 2018 s best
games motion twin is much smaller than
the Triple A companies with problematic
deep-rooted working conditions but
regardless dead cells is a challenge to
the rest of the games industry it's
proof that success doesn't require
crunch and rigid hierarchies it's an
example of a healthy studio making a
stellar piece of entertainment elsewhere
in the games industry hope endured in
the wake of Telltale's closing numerous
developers rallied to support the
affected employees Ubisoft hosted a job
fair in the Bay Area Naughty Dog's Sony
bend and Santa Monica studio shared
their job listings as well as Firaxis
games continues to work on its next
project
creative director Jake Solomon espoused
Telltale's impact on the medium and he
also shared job listings of his own
above all 2018 was a massive reminder
that people make games that people play
them and that people share them and it's
worth looking back in order to move
forward so here's two more improvements
in 2019
another year of video games
[Music]